hello everyone and welcome to another
brilliant game you guys requested me to
show it's again from the 23rd european
uh team championship and it's team
france versus uh team turkey uh alireza
ferrugia on board one uh versus mustafa
ilma's on board one representing turkey
uh it's a really wild game it features a
you know a really really awesome move
we're going to use it as opposed to
video moment uh so without further ado
let's check it out uh furuja with the
white pieces opens with e4
we have c5 uh you almost goes for the
sicilian defense knight f3 d6 and now d4
we have captures captures and knight to
f6 knight to c3 and a6 the knight of
sicilian is on the board so nothing we
haven't seen
a million times and as usual when i say
million i mean thousands we have bishop
to e3 and e5 now they are challenging
this knight here so this is the uh the
english attack basically knight to b3
and bishop to e6 now we have queen to d2
preparing the castle queen side uh and
knight b to d7 so the knight can come to
c5 but more often than not uh something
like b5 is going to be played knight to
b6 and then knight to c4 to attack the
queen and the bishop and white uh most
often against the night of has to give
up the light square bishop so here we
have castle's queen side and bishop to
e7 we have h3 uh taking care of the the
g4 square and now we have b5 black
starts the attack on the queen side
without still having castle the king's
side so g4 white of course starts
expanding on the king side as
it's expected from black to castle
kingside uh it was also um played in
2007 between
[Music]
anand and vasily vancouv where castles
was played uh
that game ended in a draw but here we
have rook to c8 and it is now uh only as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how alireza deals with
this king the b1 we want to get the king
away from the c file and now knight to
b6 preparing this knight to c4 maneuver
that we've mentioned we have g5
challenging the knight knight to h5 now
and h4 so black for a moment stop the
whites advance on the king side and
there's really nothing to advance to as
the king is still in the center of the
board so knight the c4 attacking the
queen and the bishop and like we said
bishop captures on c4 and now
you could capture with the b pawn for
example b captures on c for the knight
probably has to go to c1
and the game continues however this
closes off the c file and the black
wishes to have the the c file remain
open so here rook captures on c4 and now
knight the d5 and this is a very tricky
idea uh it's uh it's a standard win when
phase uh playing against the sicilian uh
threats against the b6 square can be
made so now it seems like you're giving
up the e4 pawn
but black can never capture this point
if black captures this just bishop b6 we
attack the queen and after queen to b8
uh and now comes this tricky knight to
a5 move and it seems like uh okay but
what's what's this if bishop captures
knight here well it's not a problem uh
but even
even more importantly if you castle just
knights the c6 and now the bishop and
the queen are attacked the queen has to
move we're gonna pick up the bishop with
checks so that's the game over and of
course if you capture the knight then
queen captures and yes the bishop is
hanging but so is the rook and now let's
say queen captures on b6 queen captures
on e4 and now queen captures on a5 uh
the problem is queen to c6 check ends
the game uh king f8 we're gonna capture
on d6 and that's it we're threatening
queen to c8 to check uh once the the
bishop blocks we can capture it and
deliver a quick checkmate doesn't matter
that this is covered twice we have
discovered as well so we're gonna have
to play captures captures with czech and
after king eight rook to d1 and that's
it there's no escape from this your
knight is terrible you can't get the
rook into the game and pretty much
whatever you play just a nice b4 ends
the game the queen now has to
leave control of this diagonal and once
the queen moves anywhere uh just queen
e6 check we're gonna play king of f8 and
rook to d8 to checkmate so uh many
possibilities here but uh you know we're
capturing on e4 is not one of them so of
course the bishop captures on d5 is
played queen captures on d5 and now we
have queen to c7 putting pressure on
this c2 pawn uh for the moment not
caring about this check if uh check is
being uh
if you play this check we can easily
block this with queen the c8 so it may
really serves no purpose so here alireza
doesn't defend the c2 pawn but plays
knight to d2 attacks the rook and he
invites black the captain
on c2 because if you capture on c2 then
rook c1 and wha what do you play now
your rook is hanging and once you play
captures captures then the queen is
hanging now queen to a8 becomes uh
somewhat of a threat and you have to
really be careful on how you continue
playing this so instead of capturing on
c2 rook back to c6 was played and now
rook to c1 now all there is i will play
c3 and double up on the c file uh black
finally castles and now we have a c3 but
in doing all of this black achieved one
thing black achieved the uh the the
shift of the game to the queen side so
can't continue pushing on the king side
there's nothing to to push with the
pawns are nicely blockaded and you can
never push f4 the knight and pawn
are making sure of that so if anything
is to be pushed it's to be pushed on the
queen side so g6 now the knight can even
come back into the game we are so maybe
knight to g7 to e6 and rook to c2 uh we
have rooked the b8 preparing to open up
the position with b4 and now rook h to
c1 we have a5 now uh preparing b4 uh and
now it's alireza who strikes with b4 and
this is a this is a really interesting
move because there is so much to play uh
here for example if you capture on b4 uh
we could play c captures on b4 and now
if rook captures and c2 rook captures
again it's not all that pleasant maybe a
queen to d7 guarding this point we're
going to play knight to b3 and now you
pretty much uh everything everything on
the under control and only white can be
better here the knight can come to a5
then to c6 and it might be a hard
position to play for black so instead
rook the c8 with the idea of giving up
the b5 pawn for the c3 pawn is now the
c3 pawn is attacked three times
but
instead of this we have a for by alireza
and this is the moment where the magic
happens so you have to decide how to uh
react to this obviously uh you should
decide between b captures on a4 and
that's pretty much it b captures on
on a4 is is your only move here uh and
the reason this is so is that yes we
will allow white to create a passport
with b5 but we're gonna uh just uh
prevent this with the queen to b8 not of
course the pawn is pinned you can't
capture and only after something like
rook to b2 we're going to play a3 and
after rook to b3 a4 and after something
like rook to b4 we're going to play rook
to c5 and it's a complete mess of a
position but black will be okay here if
we accept this bishop captures on c5
there's even knight f4 attacking the
queen and you have to do something about
this for example queen c4 rook captures
uh on c5 and after the queen moves let's
say queen f1 now we play d5 and
you know it's playable white white is
actually okay after king to a2 but it's
uh it's disgusting to even look at i
mean everyone would play black here no
one wants to be white here so this is
how you have to approach this would be
captures an a4 however in the game a
captures on b4 was played and this is
much much different
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning idea
for alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always uh
trying to look for waste the part with
your queen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
queen captures on c6 yes that's the good
stuff
it looks like uh it looks like a
completely crazy move like what what is
even happening here how is such a move
even possible
but it works uh like a charm just queen
captures on c6 and now c captures on b4
and what can black play here uh if you
want to keep your queen into the game
let's say queen to d7 we simply capture
the rook we do this with king g7 and now
even a5 and now this pass pawn is a
monster the other rook is coming to c7
there's simply nothing black can do here
if d5 trying to create some threats here
uh we still play rook 1 to c7 and now if
you go here to go after the pawn we just
play bishop to c5 and then you're gonna
lose this bishop and well there's no
coming back from this and even queen to
e6 we just attack the bishop one more
time you're going to lose the bishop on
the next move and that's all there is to
it there's no playing this for black so
black did the only thing black could he
decided to give back the queen we have
queen captures on c2 rook captures on c2
and this is what alireza had to see in
order to sacrifice the queen the way he
did um it's impossible uh for black to
go uh for this endgame rook captures
king captures and b captures on a4 it
seems like it should be possible uh
because the material is equal but after
b5 the position is winning for white and
of course it is uh calculated that
perfectly because after the bishop tries
to defend we're gonna push b6 the bishop
defends this and after let's say knight
f4 we want to bring our knight into the
game b7 bishop c7 guarding the queening
square uh bishop a7 and the next move we
bring the queen into the game and we win
this uh end game it's as simple as that
it would seem
so after rook captures on c2 of course
this trade is impossible rook the b8 is
played but now alireza creates a pass
pawn he plays a5 we have knight f4
finally the knight is being brought back
into the game now rook to c7 uh bringing
this rook to the seventh rank which also
of course means promoting it to a pig uh
the bishop is hanging here so bishop to
d8 and now rook to d7 attacking the d6
pawn and now knight to d3 black wants to
give up the d6 pawn for the b4 pawn
so now we play a6 uh how do you how do
you defend against this knight captures
on b4 grab black wins the pawn here a7
attacks the rook we have rook to a8 and
now rook captures on d6 winning back the
pawn uh preventing this bishop from ever
coming to the b6 square and the a7 pawn
is now nicely defended this rook uh
is pretty much stuck here guarding that
uh light a square forever so bishop to
c7 attacking the rook we just play rook
to d7 uh attacking the bishop uh we have
knights to a6 defending the bishop and
now rook to d5 attacking the the b5 pawn
and also knight to f3 will also go after
the e5 pawn so there's really no way for
black to hold this uh bishop the a5 was
played attacking this knight you could
try something like b4 uh trying to save
that but still knight f3 and like i said
you can to defend this pawn so in the
game bishop the a5 was played as black
was very very low on time here and
alireza just played knight to b3 and it
was in this position on move 36 that
mustafa ilma's resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the bishop is hanging the pawn is
hanging the b5 pawn is hanging and
whatever you do it will simply be
insufficient wherever the the bishop
moves to we're just going to capture on
b5 and there's no way for black to
uh to even try to play this we're still
going to win the e5 pawn and black will
simply be down too much material but i
think the real reason black resigned uh
so early on uh is that he was incredibly
low on time he was down to some 38
seconds on the clock whereas elireza had
almost i think 15 minutes
uh so yeah really really impressive game
really a sharp variation of the sicilian
and it all comes down to this uh uh
where alireza pushes a4 and b captures
on a4 is is playable and it is uh you
know the the only move for black to play
and a captures on b4 loses the game uh
but you have to see this beautiful queen
capture some c6 move that alireza played
and it was you know all downhill from uh
for for black from here so really
impressive and uh for alireza this means
that he is now on three and a half out
of four in this uh euro team
championship which is incredibly
impressive he only drew the game against
steven scharich and for those of you who
uh enjoy seeing the the shifts in
raiding uh this is the current live
standings so alireza is now to 27 89.7
so he is uh three points behind the
fabiana caruana one more win could
catapult him uh in that um
world number three spot and then you
know uh the english is next and then
we'll see how long
will it take him uh to reach magnus if
if such a thing ever happens but uh this
is the world top 23 for the moment if
you guys are interested in that you can
check it out
uh so yeah very impressive we'll see
what happens next for for our good
friend alireza uh that was the game hope
you guys uh enjoyed it i would like to
thank dave neve uh dylan's traitor uh
benjamin echenlor uh branislav pavichi
and frank ploy for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else is
happening in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day